C'était vraiment super. Merci
Mais on ne se reverra plus jamais.
Je suis mariée.
Putain !
Au revoir, Madame !
Je m'en fous que tu sois mariée.
Je t'aime toujours.
Tu connais ce type ?
C'était un coup d'un soir.
Mon mari m'a trompée.
Je cherchais quelqu'un avec qui coucher
pour me venger.
C'est la dernière femme mariée que tu te seras tapé
Non non non
Oh mon Dieu
Ne tirez pas !
T'as mouillé ton pantalon.
Vous me mettez un flingue sous le nez et j'avais déjà envie de pisser.
L'infidélité de Morgane
m'a encouragé à prendre des vacances.
J'emménage ici quelque temps.
Quoi ?
Vous aviez dit que ça ressemblait à un bateau pirate
et que ça sentait les nouilles au bœuf.
Et tu as répondu que ça sentait l'homme.
Et tu avais raison.
Grady ! Qu'est-ce que tu fais ici ?
Je vis ici maintenant.
Notre haine pour toi nous a rapproché.
Morgane, je..je dirai pas que je te hais
Tu peux la fermer ?
S'il te plait.
Bien sûr, je.. j'arrête de parler.
Tu parles trop. Stop
C'est trop tordu.
On doit sortir, on doit se trouver des nanas.
Il faut que je me tape quelqu'un.
Non !
Si !
Noon !
Bois ça : 92 pourcents d'alcool.
Ca va ?
Ouais.
C'était, un bain moussant incroyable.
Les aventures te suivent.
Bah je déteste ça.
J'ai couché avec le seul mec
qui peut pas supporter que son coup d'un soir soit un coup d'un soir.
Je suis impatient de tous les écarter de ma vie.
T'es tellement bizarre.
Tu es mon pion
T'es baisée.
C'est quoi votre problème ?!
C'est pas drôle.
C'est ça le mariage.
C'est un grand décérébré. Ils le sont tous.
Qu'il boive dans la botte du clochard !